for some reason linus torvald comes to
mind but he you know there's people who
criticize you he rules the iron fist man
but there's still charisma there's a
charisma right there's a charisma to
that iron fist uh there's a
every leader is different i would say in
their success so he doesn't
i don't even know if you can say he
doesn't have humility
uh there's such a meritocracy of ideas
that like
this is a good idea and this is a bad
idea there's a step function to it once
you clear a threshold yeah he's open
once you clear the bozo threshold he's
open to your ideas i think yes right but
see the the interesting thing is
obviously that will not stand in an open
source community
if that threshold that is defined by
that one particular person
is not actually that good
so you actually have to be really
excellent at what you do
so the the he's very good at what he
does and so there's some aspect of
leadership where
you can get thrown out people can just
leave you know that's how it works with
open source yeah they'll fork
but at the same time you want to
sometimes be a leader like with a strong
opinion because people i mean there's
some kind of balance here for this like
hive mind to get like behind leadership
is a big topic and i didn't you know i'm
not one of these guys that went to mba
school and said i'm going to be an
entrepreneur and i'm going to be a
leader and i'm going to read all these
hardware business review articles on
leadership and all this other stuff like
it i was a physicist turned into a
software nerd who then really like
nerded out on python um i know i am
entrepreneurial right i saw a business
opportunity around the use of python
data but um for me
what has been interesting over this
journey with the last 10 years is how
much i started really
enjoying the
understanding thinking deeper about
organizational dynamics and leadership
and leadership does come down to
a few core things number one
a leader has to create belief or at
least has to dispel disbelief
leadership also you have to have vision
loyalty and experience
you